here we go again so the first official
trailer because what we got before was
only a teaser for justice Lee came out
over the weekend now normally I try and
turn these videos around a little bit
faster than this but you know what I
took the weekend for myself and I was
away and having a rather lovely time and
then I then I saw this so this is a
little later than I would usually like
to be but i'm going to share my thoughts
anyways now before I get too into just
all the things that really make me very
depressed about this thing i'll start by
acknowledging this if you liked Batman V
Superman I know there are people who did
and did so genuinely and i'm jealous
that you did because i didn't but if you
are one of those people look at this
trailer you're probably going to be very
happy because this is very much looking
feeling sounding akin to Batman V
Superman it it's super Snyder II it's
really really Zack Snyder e so if you
dig that I think you're probably like
you think like industrail you probably
be very happy with the movie if you are
more like me and batman v superman you
there were a handful of things that you
were like that's okay that's not bad
that's kind of cool but it was all
wrapped in this just mess then this
trailer does not bring a lot of comfort
so if you don't know sort of where you
fall if you're on the fence you're like
maybe the trailers he was kind of cool
like minded sup mmm assume it was ok
lighting you're not sure how you feel
about this I'm going to give you a
little shortcut here my friend Paul who
had been on the show up on occasion and
who has actually done screenwriting
before so he has a final draft and he
did a little test and he took the
opening lines of this trailer plug them
in to final draft to see if it looked as
stupid on paper as it sounded to his ear
so I'm going to put that up on the
screen right now so if you're looking at
this and you're thinking that looks
really dumb then this is probably not
going to be a good time for you I want
to thank Paul for that because
I really think in many ways seeing it
like that does more than then I could
actually do much thing but i'm going to
try saying stuff anyway so like i said
really snyder e lots of speed ramping a
ton of CGI are really on the nose music
choice just all of the things that you
expect from zack snyder at this point i
tell you there's that one shot of Wonder
Woman eyes were like she sweeps a guy's
leg or something I was so grateful for
that shot cuz it was like the first one
for hell I got the trailer that wasn't
just saturated CGI and it looked like a
shot where there was nothing that wasn't
real and everything was there was like
oh wow thank god i just it just the
noise and the fury of that especially
that climax in Batman V Superman it just
it lost me completely cuz I felt like
there was nothing that I could grab on
to because i was watching pixels
smashing pixels and not that that can't
work i mean i unabashedly enjoyed avatar
but that one at was all set in an
artificial world so it kind of gets a
little bit more leeway than suddenly is
supposedly set in the real world so I'm
kind of jumping all over voice what are
we actually getting this we get a little
kind of mini introductions on Aquaman
the flash and cyborgs cyborg could spend
the least amount of time on which is odd
because he's the one that I think folks
are least likely to know anything about
you think he'd be the one that they
would sell the hardest and he was the
one that they sold the hardest in Batman
V Superman but here he's just like
little bit we hear Wonder Woman call him
a cyborg he gets one line we spent a lot
more time with Jason Momoa as Aquaman
and with Ezra Miller as the flash now
Jason Momoa as Aquaman the look is cool
I do think it's a good look and then for
the look they're going for he is a good
match for that look I got if he at his
line just like a bat I did get I was
like I don't know how I feel about that
and then at the end when he's on the
Batmobile he goes yeah I was gone I mean
I was it forget it I'm gone it's
actually rewatching the trail because I
washed it again before I recording this
I actually had the thought because
cyborg has is
moment we like saves a cop it like stops
a cop car from crushing him or something
and he goes like you might want to run
or move you know something just very
sort of Stowe's Barry I'm here to help
let me help and I'm there thinking they
swap cyborg and Aquaman personalities at
the script phases that what happened I
mean that I'm saying that kind of
facetiously because I understand there
have been many variations of the
personalities I'll both of these
characters i'm not saying either one is
invalid but I'm saying like in my mind
sort of the default standard personality
type for the young you know college
football star versus the regal Lord of
Atlantis my default for what those
pirzada should be are the opposite of
what we're getting and that's funny me
to say that that couldn't work it's just
weird and jarring Ezra Miller is the
flash I don't know man you just got a
rough go of it because Grant Gustin he's
going into season 4 of the flash and
he's a version of / said pretty much all
the fans like even if there's an
feelings on the show overall are a
little bit up and down Ezra Miller he
seems to be doing fine I just don't know
what they're going to do to distinguish
this version now it looks like would the
angle that they've gone because at this
point we've seen speedsters not only on
the flash TV show but we've gotten two
versions a Quicksilver on the big screen
so doing speedsters on screen is not new
anymore so it looks like what they're
going for for their unique version is to
actually not slow down time with him but
to happen but to show a lot more of it
in normal time which means we're seeing
him almost looks like he's teleporting
like there's a blur and suddenly he's
over there and so we see that we only
see like that same little bit of time
slowing down that we saw from the
original teaser and most of the other
stuff seems to be us not either not
quite keeping up with him or us and
almost be watching him blast past and
maybe shifting that emphasis rather than
doing like the days of future past thing
where we slow down to be with the
speedster that might be the better way
of going just so it doesn't feel as
played out Ben Affleck is Batman
I just I feel sad about that at this
point because I still think he's a good
match for the role and like the Vikings
gave me off his okay but he saddled with
the oh god the lines that in addition to
the 1i already put up that just his
response to Barry Allen's question
what's your superpower Organa I'm
sitting there there's a pause first of
all before having something don't say
I'm rich don't Sam Urick don't say I'm
rich I'm rich it's just it's super
obvious writing is what it like the
whole trailer it's very it's very
obvious and again that that I don't know
if that's a fair criticism to actually
level against the thing because i mean
it is the first full-length trailer but
at the same time I mean this isn't
justice league we know what this is we
know yo the lineup is going to be I
don't know if this sort of let's go
through the the new members of the team
point for point is is the way you had to
go I mean that is that's just the
generic way you kind of do you know a
team trailer to lay everybody out but I
mean it's the Justice League the reason
they're jumping to justice league with
as few movies underneath a young for the
individual stars as they are is because
they DC Warner Brothers seems to have
assumed everybody knows these characters
we can get right to the team movie and
yet you're treating the marketing
material like we don't know who they are
and I again I don't know if that's
entirely fair as a criticism it just it
all feels weird and jumbled and not well
headed it I don't just mean the director
within Zack Snyder and mint seriously a
lot of these shots reminded me a hell of
a lot of sucker punch not just BBS but
sucker punch ah but even beyond that it
feels like there's a lack of guidance
and a lack of coherence and you know
what I'm actually going to go back to
something that came up that occurred to
me during the teasers for this trailer
because we got a little brief flashes of
Aquaman and cyborgs and I think flat I
can't remember now but they they were
using taglines unites the league sounds
good but also sounds oddly familiar what
unites seven right and the marketing
push
to VV to VBS they use quite a bit this
line of unite the seven who's the seven
right now in this league it as we're
seeing it we've got five we've got
Batman Wonder Woman Aquaman flash and
cyborgs now if you want to extend it and
add Superman who's going to come back if
not by the end of this one that's
certainly the next Justice League movie
that gets us up to six so um who's the
seventh and this is not me leading into
some kind of speculation I know the
secret seven no this is me pointing at
ongoing see they have no idea what
they're doing because at some point they
were sure oh really going to be seven
here's united seven will use this as an
early push yeah they don't say that
anymore you know why cuz there's no
seven there is no seventh it doesn't
exist so they thought they thought they
had a plan at some point and that's
obviously not what they're currently
doing anymore something has changed and
yet and that's obviously plans can
change plans can absolutely change but
when you're so forming your plan that
you're going to stick this thing though
isn't going to mean something for years
it's theoretically and you're going to
stick it in your early marketing
material then abandon it because it
doesn't make sense anymore because
you've taken you know that just is that
shift of appearing so certain but so
obviously not being certain about what
you're doing that is just it's the
disconnect of these movies they have to
go forward with this sense that they
have a bold vision and it's a plan as
like don't worry we know what we're
doing but everything just indicates that
they don't know what they're doing and
they're making it up as they go along
and I will be shocked if Zack Snyder's
allowed to direct any more after this
I'll let unless and delay it's the same
caveat i put on Wonder Woman unless it
turns out to be really good and is
really well received and is not as
divisive as Batman V Superman was
because even if it turns a decent profit
which odds are it will if it is a
divisive as batman be superman Warner
Bros is going to kick Zack Snyder to the
curb raw real fast again speaking
personally I'm fine with because I'm
doubled with the Snyder II looking stuff
I the guy's not untalented as a visual
storyteller but when allowed to just go
nuts which he did would be
yes which he did with sucker punch which
it looks like he's doing here I don't
think the results are very good the
man's at his best when he's reined in or
focused better with something like 300
dawn of the dead even watchman which I'm
actually not even that big of a fan of
he seemed much more focused in that one
than he has in these are the last few
and then this one looks to me but again
if you like BBS this looks like it'll be
a good time for you me I'll be staying
home so that's my thoughts on the
Justice League trailer have you seen it
of course you have what were your
thoughts on ax whatever they were drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to
council geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]